when Tim Burton's The Nightmare Before
Christmas premiered in October 1993 it
did so with surprisingly little fanfare
for a film developed by Disney it was
only after the film left theaters that
it began a transition from beloved cult
movie to cultural phenomenon the story
of how this creepy classic came about is
just as interesting as the film itself
here's the untold truth of the Nightmare
Before Christmas it comes from a poem
Burton originally penned the movie's
story as a poem when he was working as
an animator for Disney which he likened
being stuck in a prison Burton could
never adapt to the style preferred by
Disney which became clear to him while
working on the 1981 feature the Fox and
the Hound saying I couldn't draw those
four-legged Disney foxes mine look like
Road kills Burton left Disney but kept
in touch with another struggling
animator Henry Selick Burton shared is
haunting poem about a skeletal figure
named Jack Skellington with Selleck who
showed immediate interest in directing a
feature version production started in
1991 but not without some trouble salic
didn't even have a full script in the
beginning all he had was Burton's best
wishes and a few of Danny Elfman songs
to go on Disney got scared
Disney initially considered turning
Burton's holiday-themed poem into a TV
special or a short film similar to
Vincent a 1982 short film also based on
a Burton poem but it backed out the
success of 1988 s Beetlejuice and 1990s
Edward Scissorhands gave Burton enough
negotiating power to arrange a deal with
Disney and the project was finally
greenlit with Burton acting as the
go-between for the studio and his
director but after seeing the first
trailer then chairman CEO Michael Eisner
decided that the Nightmare Before
Christmas was just too dark for Disney
the film was sent away from the kids
table to touchstone pictures where
Disney kept content they didn't want
associated with a child-friendly brand
what's wrong with disembodied legs and
children with sewn shut eyes anyhow
isn't that basically their slogan
filming took over three years hailing
from before the days of slick CGI the
effort that went into making the
Nightmare Before Christmas was intense
the film was shot at 24 frames per
second which meant that the characters
had to be repositioned 24 times for
every second of film it took a whole
week to create just a single minute of
footage and eight camera crews worked at
once it wasn't just a case of nudging a
figurine slightly either the characters
had to be carefully disassembled and
reassembled for every frame so the
facial expressions matched what was
happening on-screen the pumpkin King had
more than 400 interchangeable heads
alone boogy boogy was trouble despite
being a burlap sack filled with creepy
crawlies nightmares antagonist Oogie
Boogie was actually the hardest
character to create his complex demise
in the film was particularly tricky to
navigate consisting of four shots that
each took a full month to make not only
that but the metal armature inside the
huge figure was so strong that animators
had to get behind it and push it into
place for each shot says no wonder he's
barely in the film Santa Claus huh some
viewers also felt that Kim pages
portrayal of the villain burj don racist
Selleck defended the character insisting
the page modeled his voice performance
on Cab Calloway this argument is
supported by the fact that some lines of
dialogue are lifted directly from the
1933 Betty Boop cartoon the Old Man of
the Mountain star in Callaway gonna do
the best I can
what are you going to do I'm gonna do
the best I can composer Danny Elfman has
a long history of channeling Calloway as
well as he did in the 1980 film
Forbidden Zone
let me tell you I'm so pleased to meet
you
the boys and I brothers better to greet
you best friends for never all of Jack
Skellington songs were composed and sung
by Engel blingo frontman danny elfin
himself
that's nightmare trivia 101 but Elfman
also recorded all the pumpkin Kings
speaking parts too while he nailed the
singing Alvin's voice acting just wasn't
up to Selleck standards and in the end
Burton and Selleck decided they would
have Chris Sarandon rerecord the scenes
Elfman took it badly refusing to score
Burton's next film Atwood Elfman still
got his speaking voice in the film kind
of the world renowned composer also
voiced the clown with the tearaway face
and barrel the smallest of oogie-boogies
miniature henchman creator cameos in the
end
Elmas voice being in the movie just
wasn't enough and he had the animators
create a shrunken version of his head
and hide it inside a cello Tim Burton's
severed head was also supposed to appear
in the film's finale as a hockey puck
but the projectile was changed to a
jack-o'-lantern at the last moment rumor
has it the Disney deemed the inclusion
of their former employees head a step
too far and leaned on Selleck to change
it doctor in disguise the biggest reveal
from the unearthed storyboards was a
twist ending when Oogie Boogie sack
starts to unravel it isn't just worms
and spiders that come spilling out dr.
Finklestein is in there too yes Jack
Skellington it's me me the man who
created Sally from bits of flesh and
scraps of cloth but she loves you
Jack you oblivious twit a defiant
Finkelstein explains he wanted to teach
Sally a lesson before declaring his
intentions to make a new creation and
disappearing through a trapdoor
the doctors gross new creation can be
seen in the film's finale why anyone
would choose a wife that looked exactly
like themselves is anyone's guess but
those reasons are probably pretty weird
lost voices like Chris Sarandon
many of the film's voices weren't the
creator's original choices Burton had
worked with Vincent Price on two
productions prior to nightmare but their
collaboration
a nightmare had to be called off
unexpectedly price came into the studio
to record the voice of Santa but when
the veteran actor was too depressed
after losing his wife they were forced
to consider alternatives James Earl
Jones had discussions with Elfman that
ended at an angry shouting match in the
end at ivory a relative unknown was
entrusted with the part Patrick Stewart
was also brought on the nightmare early
on in its development recording a film
linked bad app tation of the poem I'm
sick of the scaring the terror the
fright I'm tired of being something that
goes bump in the night in the end it was
decided that the opening verses would be
better recited by the film Santa and the
Stewart version ended up on the cutting
room floor DVD extras and the film's
official soundtrack poorer veteran
Christopher Lee also read the full
length poem for the film but was also
ultimately cut due his disappointment
I'm sick of the scouting Bonterra the
fright I'm tired of being something that
goes bump in the night but as we all
know Lee is no stranger to being stabbed
in the back skeleton babies the last
that Jack and old Sandy Claws see if
each other is when Santa flies out of
sight leaving Halloween town under a
blanket of snow in an unused epilogue
scene however Santa reveals that he
actually visited his old friend Jack
years after their holidays disastrously
crossed paths and found him with a
handful of musically inclined children
by his side so many years later I
thought I'd drop in
there was old Jack still looking quite
thin with four or five skeleton children
at hand playing strange little tunes in
their xylophone man those kids actually
sound a lot like goggle boy go now that
we think about it there's kind of a
sequel and a prequel in the mid-2000s
Capcom released a video game called
boogies revenge which takes place after
the events the film Jack gets bored with
his life again ouki is sewn back
together by his trio of henchmen and the
burlap sack decides he wants to be the
king of all holidays not just Halloween
the game ends pretty much identically to
the film with Oggy once again defeated
and Jack once again rededicated to his
true calling of Halloween no one said it
was a great story but there's a
videogame prequel also the pumpkin King
released at the same time as the sequel
actually explains the huge gaps in the
film's continuity the conflict and
jealousy between Jack and Yugi is
explored as well as exactly why okie has
to live underground in his lair spoiler
alert it's because once again he lost a
fight with Jack Jack's cameos burden is
declared he'll never create a real The
Nightmare Before Christmas sequel
especially not one where Jack goes to
Arbor Day town or something Humes me is
this on a good home now in thematic in
the nightclub um but that didn't stop
Selleck from returning to the character
twice in his 1996 adaptation of Roald
Dahl's James of Giant Peach
the brigade of mutant insects face off
against Jack as if pirate with one even
declaring well Skellington
the skeletal master of horror does his
job pretty well but that's not even his
only cameo SELEX 2009 stop-motion film
Coraline if folks nightmare in a number
of ways though those were the kenai were
able to spot a direct reference as core
lines mother cracks eggs over Bowl
Jack's grinning skull can be seen inside
one of the dripping yolks it's almost a
literal easter egg but it's so quick
it's easy to miss others not so much
[Music]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to